it this set is commonly known as the poly group we could also consider the set
generated by just x and z and we end up getting half of the poly group in this case
and one final example at least for now we can consider the set generated by X tensor x and z tensor Z so n is equal to
two in this case and we end up getting just four elements this time owing to the fact that X tensor x and z tensor Z
commute with one another poly matrices and N Cubit poly operations more generally describe
unitary operations whether they're errors or they're intentional but they also describe
measurements to be more precise starting with just the three non-identity poly matrices we can associate each of these
matrices with a projective measurement defined in terms of its igen values and igen vectors and here on the screen we
have spectral decompositions of these matrices that will help to clarify this in essence when we refer to an X
measurement a y measurement or a z measurement we mean the projective measurement defined by the projections
onto the igen spaces of these matrices and commonly we think about the igen value vales as being the corresponding
measurement outcomes for example an X measurement is a measurement with respect to the plus
minus basis of a cubit or alternatively we can describe it by the set containing the projections Kat plus BR plus and K
minus bra minus a z measurement on the other hand is nothing more than a standard basis
measurement although like I said we sometimes identify the igen values with the measurement outcomes and if we do
that then the outcomes are plus and minus one as opposed to 0 and one respectively we can in fact do something
along these lines for arbitrary hermi matrices and the term observable is commonly used in this situation for poly
matrices and encubate poly operations more generally we can perform such measurements non-destructively using
phase estimation and just to be sure that this diagram is clear here we're performing the measurements non-destructively on
the top Cubit whereas the bottom cubit is always initialized to a plus state or in other words a hadamard applied to a
zero State because that's how phase estimation Works notice that because the I values
are just plus one and minus one in this case we only need one control Cubit which is the bottom cubid in this
diagram any more than that would just be a waste because there is only one bit of precision to worry about the ion value
is either plus one or minus one and the measurement is already perfect just like this the outcome of this measurement by
the way meaning the standard basis measurement in the circuit will be zero for the plus one igen value outcome
which corresponds to the plus state in the case of an X observable and the outcome is one for the minus one ion
value or the minus state in this case everything I just said extends naturally to ncit poly operations
provided that we keep in mind that when we think about an observable we're talking about measuring the igen values
not measuring with respect to a basis of igen vectors for example consider the two
Cubit poly operation Z tensor Z once again there are two igen values plus one and minus one so the
measurement is described by two projections notice in particular that the measurement that we associate with
this observable is not the same as measuring both cubits with a z measurement or in other words a standard basis measurement but rather it's a two
outcome projective measurement where the projections are onto the spaces spend by all of the IG vectors corresponding to
each of the two igen values plus one and minus one another way of thinking about this is that the igen values of a tensor
product are products of the IG values of the individual matricies that we're taking the tensor products of and
because negative 1 * negative 1 is the same as positive 1 * positive 1 for instance this measurement doesn't
distinguish between 0 0 and 1 one so if we were to measure say a five plus Bell state with the measurement
described by this observable we would be certain to obtain the outcome corresponding to the I Value Plus One
and the state would be unchanged as opposed to collapsing to 0 0 or 1 one which is what would happen if we
performed the standard basis measurements on the two cubits so a zensor z measurement is not
the same thing as performing to Z measurements independently but we can in fact perform measurements like this using phase
estimat in precisely the same way as before using a single control Cubit as is shown in the circuit diagram which
generalizes to any n Cubit poly operation in place of Z tensor Z when we have just Z poly matrices by
the way we can simplify the circuit like this and what this reveals which is also evident from the projections that Define
the measurement is that performing a z tensor Z measurement on two cubits is equivalent to measuring their parity
thinking in terms of the standard basis and this generalizes to the tensor product of any number of poly Z
matrices next we'll take a second look at the three-bit repetition code this time phrasing it in terms of poly
operations this will be our first rather simple example of a stabilizer code and we'll discuss how to generalize this
notion shortly but it is helpful to see how it works in this simple case first recall that when we apply the
3-bit repetition code to cubits we encode a given Cubit State Alpha 0 plus beta 1 as Alpha 0000 0 plus beta 11 1 1
and we'll give this three Cubit encoding the name Sai for convenience so by definition s is a valid three Cubit
encoding of a cubit state but if we want to check this it suffices to check that the following two equations are true the
first equation states that applying Z operations to the leftmost two cubits of s does nothing to S which is to say that
SII is an igen vector of Z tensor Z tensor Identity or just ZZ identity for short with ion value one and the second
equation is similar except that Z operations are applied to the rightmost two cubits the idea is if we think about S
as a linear combination of standard basis States then the first equation implies that we can only have non-zero coefficients for standard basis states
where the leftmost two bits have even parity or equivalently are equal and the second equation implies that we can only
have non-zero coefficients for standard basis States for which the rightmost two bits have even parity another way to think about this
is to view these two poly operations as observables and if we were to measure these two observables using the
simplified circuit I mentioned just a moment ago then we would be certain to obtain a measurement outcome corresponding to plus one igen values
because s is an igen Vector of both observables with igen value one but this simplified version of the combined